thank you very much Bobby when this had
a similar situation when I was working
at the British Library was we just
finished the Center for conservation of
25 million dollar project it was such a
celebration and the night before and the
architects of the British Library died
what we decided to go ahead with it the
celebration because in honor of him and
so when Bobby told me the news just
earlier we decided to to go ahead with
the talk in Frank's honor and I would
have been meeting with him tomorrow as
two newbies he was two months into being
the university librarian and I'm six
months into being deputy director of
Harvard University Library so we'll go
ahead so this is a talk that Bobby
invited me to give about a year ago and
it's an enormous privilege and honor to
be invited to give the talk will turn
the lights down in a second and it's a
it's a privilege to be giving it to this
to this audience because I was thinking
about it there's only a couple of things
to which I think I can lay claim and one
of them is that I'm guessing that I'm
the only brother Helen in the audience
and the reason that I'm brother helen is
that I'm an associate of the art workers
guild which was set up in the UK germ
doing the Arts and Crafts movement and
and we're all brethren hence the brother
Helen and I was taken there and
introduced to it by Roger Powell who
rebound the Book of Kells together with
his partner Douglas [ __ ] wall who
rebound the Codex Sinaiticus and his son
sandy cockle and they laid the
foundation of Book and Manuscript
conservation I think in the UK and
they're out influences travel very
widely
Peter waters at the Library of Congress
well Bobby invited me to give this talk
last year and I think I'm still slightly
surprised to obtain the train this
morning from Boston instead of having
flown across from Heathrow this time
last year when Bobby invited me I was at
the British Library where I was part of
the senior leadership team and I was
head of collection care I was
responsible for the care of 115 million
items and 300 terabytes of electronic
content and those collections and that
content it ranged from medieval
manuscripts and papaya I and oracle
bones through two literary authors
emails and websites of the UK web domain
so in my time at the BL we completed the
Center for conservation we'd recently
finished the 135 miles of storage of the
storage building that built on the Yale
Harvard Model taib a high-density
robotic low oxygen storage and half a
mile of stock a day was being moved into
that facility I was involved with the
newspaper strategy which was dealing
with 750 million pages of news for
newsprint the digital library system was
under way and I distr helped establish
the digital preservation and that went
from seven years ago when there was not
a single digital preservation
professional in a UK library archive and
I had to poach from Australia to when I
left we then just had a retreat and then
around the table there was now a hundred
years of experience in digital
preservation and I was also just
finishing the stewardship strategy for
the British library's physical and
virtual collections for the next ten
years so that was a year ago when Bobby
invited me to give the talk scroll
forward a year and I've now been at
Harvard six months currently responsible
for the programs across the system of 73
libraries
so that's information systems archives
and records management preservation
conservation high-density store and the
office for scholarly communications
which champions open access these
provide the services across the library
system which you probably know is a very
decentralized system plus you may also
know that at Harvard last year the
president and provost instigated a task
force to look at the future of the
entire 73 library system from a
governance of funding in a structural
perspective on my second day I joined
the task forces work and it's looking at
the strategic future of the library
system it's due to report in the near
future and so it wouldn't be appropriate
for me to comment on that major
fundamental review now but there are
already key directions that came out
clearly for example working towards one
integrated collection and being user
centric or putting the user as our
primary focus well for this talk and
they're going to pick out five or six
paradoxes that I've been pondering
around preservation even though it's now
not my primary focus and as this is
billed as a personal and strategic
perspective it's my take on things
through the lens of having just moved
3276 miles and through the lens of
having journeyed from an artisan
conservation to strategic management I'm
going to use a couple of examples from
the British Library because you probably
already know a lot about Harvard and may
not be so acquainted with the BL so a
year ago I was working at the British
Library one of the greatest research
libraries in the world and now i'm at
harvard one of the greatest research
libraries in the world the british
library now has a well-integrated
preservation and conservation setup of
which i am extremely proud
when Harvard has an extremely impressive
preservation and conservation setup and
on a personal note I'd like to pay
tribute to John Merrill Alden who
retired last month her forethought and
very wise decisions have created a very
professional department and on as aside
if anyone wants to talk to me at the
reception will be recruiting to that
post later in the earth the British
Library has a stupendous and slightly
irrational legacy from over 250 years
and Harvard has a phenomenal historical
legacy of over 350 years so they both
have magnificent pasts and I'll start
with a very obvious simple paradox
namely the people often think
preservation is all about the past but
to my mind it's all about the future
it's about anticipating the future
rather than adhering to the past and
being able to look a user of the future
in the metaphoric lie and say well we
did our best to meet present needs and
anticipate your needs and that's also
the user centricity that Harvard's task
force is talking about so from a simple
one to earn the next paradox there's
been lots of talk that the rise in
digital initiatives leads to the demise
of the book and a lot of anxiety that
that leads to a demise and the need for
preservation paradoxically not
necessarily and whatever it's not that
simple yes last year excuse me last week
amazon said it sold more ebooks on
amazon com during the previous 30 days
than print books that's both hardcover
and paperback combined of its bestseller
list
yes we're seeing the complete life cycle
of the media did you see that it's only
this week last week actually and it
stopped making its Walkman tapes so
that's a 30 year full life cycle come
and gone yes Generation X Generation Y
in generation said all those digital
natives they have got expectations of
access to everything at any time in any
place anywhere brewster kahle the
internet archiver he recently estimated
that a hundred million books will be
disposed of across the u.s. in the next
ten years these are not unique items but
if they are disposed of ironically they
might become more special so here's the
paradox brewster kahle one of the
earliest people to realize the fragility
of websites and do something about it by
setting up the wayback machine in the
internet archive in order to preserve
the web so he quintessential internet
archive ER is setting up a physical
repository and is welcoming and will
store store discarded copies as everyone
digitizes and discards what the Bristol
Cale example illustrates is that the
physical is taking on greater
significance when its existence is
threatened which is leading to a greater
emphasis on preservation ironically when
where there has been concern that
preservation is threatened I'm going to
read you a quote taken from last month's
launch of the British library's vision
for 2020 to put this in context this
strategic vision was posted just ahead
of the comprehensive spending review
which was the fundamental review of all
federal funding all federal spawn
spending by the new coalition government
that's looking at everything from
defense to education to health and in
the event it made nineteen percent cuts
in government spending across the whole
of the UK
my colleague at the BL could be
profiling twenty-five percent and forty
percent cuts she made the raika meant I
never thought I'd say Helen that fifteen
percent would be a good result anyway
this is the BLS vision for 2020 could
you turn the lights down please
we estimate that by 2020 75% of all
titles worldwide will be published in
digital form only or in both digital and
print our ambition is to preserve
digital content for the long term in
order to safeguard our intellectual
heritage that it can be used by future
generations of researchers as digital
formats become the norm our rich
resource of physical content will become
more precious it is thus vital that we
continue to develop our world-class
stewardship skills in conservation and
preservation so paradoxically more
preservation of more precious physical
material whilst also there's obviously
the rise in digital preservation this
from an organization that is absolutely
positioning itself in the forefront of
the digital world so the Prime Minister
launched digital Britain from the
British Library when I was there last
year furthermore digitization excuse me
digitization can lead to greater
emphasis and importance on the special
physical not less and virtualization is
leading to the creation of new digital
entities and as the mass digitization
related initiatives such as Google and
the boutique digitization of small
projects start to join up they make for
a new critical mass a new massive
digital entity that can be linked and
mind and studied and used in ways that
were unimaginable unimaginable until
recently and I'll illustrate this with
the digitization and virtual and virtual
reunification of the Codex Sinaiticus
which is the earliest existing text in
the world of the New Testament
so one of the only other claims I can
make is that until the 6th of July last
year I was one of maybe three people
alive who had seen all the surviving
manuscript of the Codex Annie Atticus in
the four locations namely some
catherine's monastery in Egypt from
where the majority was taken in the 19th
century by tischendorf to Leipzig in
Germany and then it went to some
Petersburg and then to London on the 60
excuse me on the sixth of July last year
the digitized manuscripts were brought
together virtually and instead of there
being having being seen by three people
in the world on that day alone they were
viewed by 20 million people so the Codex
Sinaiticus project digitized all the
leaves and fragments from the four
locations there are 347 leaves in the
British Library in London bought from
the Russian government in 1933 for the
equivalent of about three million
dollars and they arrived unbound and
were bound into two volumes in 1935 by
toddlers cockrell when I work for Roger
pal he used to tell us stories about
cockles conservation and binding of the
Codex and so from a personal point of
view there was a lovely circularity in
being in leading the conservation of the
Codex Sinaiticus project some 60 years
later and finding in the archives all
the materials testing and all the
treatments and all the correspondence
between powell and cockrell then there
are 43 leaves in Leipzig University
Library in Germany and those are
currently unbound there are four
portions of leaves in the National
Library of Russia in some Petersburg and
those are currently framed and then
there are some or all of 18 leaves and
some catherine's monastery and Mount
Sinai in Egypt
they were recovered by the monks from
the northern wall of the monastery in
1975 and from a conservation point of
view there in the worst condition the
project was essentially to digitize the
leaves and bring the manuscript back
together on the web to reunify virtually
but it was much more than that so there
was imaging under standard light and
raking light and then there's the
content metadata there's a new transfer
transcription it's in Greek and the text
is in Greek so there's a new
transcription into Greek there are
translations into modern Greek Russian
German and English and then there's the
physical description this physical
description was part of the conservation
element of the project with major
collaboration with the curatorial
investigations with extensive
examination of the scribe link the code
ecological features the previous repairs
the current condition conservation
undertaken and all of all the surface
characteristics of the parchment so for
example here you can see those curves on
the left hand side there are striations
made by the thought to be made by the
parchment makers knives the same
documentation methodology was used in
each of the four locations and then
embed it in the website so I'm not aware
of this level of examination being so
systematically embedded in any other
such project and it's great to hear I've
just learned that it's been shortlisted
for the UK's conservation awards and
then there's a whole series of essays on
the website which are being consistently
added to now this was a seven year one
and a half million dollar project the
next step was through was a much shorter
less expensive project to digitize all
the British library's Greek manuscripts
building on what was learned from the
Codex Sinaiticus project and UD using
crowdsourcing so what was being called
as I left
the British Library expert on amis where
by scholars input their research so that
it wasn't just BL experts writing the
text and then there were folks on amis
whereby non-scholars could input their
there so taking it from being a boutique
digitization project to a wider project
country contributing to this critical
mass of content so here's the thing
here's the paradox articulated on the
day that the world's earliest surviving
text of the New Testament was virtually
reunified on the day that 20 million
people saw it reunified on the day that
the term codex sinaiticus was amongst
the top 20 google searches worldwide and
on the day that there are over 700 news
articles about the project on that day
on 6th of july two thousand nine on the
guardian newspaper's blog surely dint of
the Institute of ideas she said we've
long been aware that a plethora of
literature can be made available through
digitized open sources such as Project
Gutenberg but ironically the potential
to make literature available online in
downloadable and now ebook reader format
has also been heralded as the slow death
of the book as we know it what the Codex
Sinaiticus project illustrates is that
the opposite could be true digital
technology may not only preserve hard
codices that even with the best
conservation intentions will always be
vulnerable to the ravages of time we may
in fact be on the brink of digitally
resurrecting reinterpreting and
reinvigorating that past
my third paradox is around the
inevitable classic tension between
preservation and access which has been
debated since the beginning of
preservation as a as a profession
personally I pretty much changed my
views since starting as a naive and
idealistic conservator at the Victoria
and Albert Museum when I first thought
the best way to preserve fragile
materials was to prevent damage by
keeping people away from fragile special
collections now my starting point is how
to make things accessible and then work
backwards there's an inherent paradox in
making material available nicely
summarized I think in a recent UK
research project entitled catch-22 the
catch-22 where is that access to
heritage objects make bring social
benefit greater access brings greater
social benefit greater access brings
greater damage and greater damage brings
reduced social benefit so access bring
social benefit greater access greater
social benefit greater access greater
damage greater damage reduce social
benefit
one approach to squaring this particular
circle is to take a strategic management
approach whenever we make material
available we're putting it at risk and I
was very much involved in collection
security in my last roll so thankful for
smiley the third Farhad Hawkins our day
there was a case reported only last week
of the ex department head of the
National Archives here arrested in his
house by FBI agents but the risk to
collections is far wider than from theft
there's a whole risk and compliance
industry that analyzes probability and
severity of risks and in the world of
conservation and preservation there are
various methods for assessing risk of
collections to example that developed at
the Canadian Museum of Nature most of
you will know this method but it defines
agents of deterioration and risk factors
for example earthquakes pests
environmental factors dissociation which
is a renaming of that previously
somewhat pejorative custodial neglect
and security and so on ironically I
think an integrated risk management
approach encourages innovation and
entrepreneurship which we hear so much
about and it encourages risk-taking
because it encourages an organization to
identify risks identify mitigation of
risks and actually to be explicit about
what its risk appetite is it compels an
organization to acknowledge what's risky
identify the unknown give a name to fear
and fear of failure and then that can
help inform your strategy risk
assessments were carried out on all the
collections at the British Library so
here's the British Library and there was
a risk assessment of all the digital
collections which helped determine the
digital preservation strategy so for
example we discovered there's already
three percent loss of legal deposit cds
and then we did a risk assessment of the
physical collections using the Canadian
Museum of nature's methodology and the
two highest risks I was going to ask
what people thought they were but I
can't see anyone actually was it would
you shout out what do you think were the
two highest risks of the 150 million
physical items of the British Library
being lost okay any others water damage
actual okay any others interesting yes
when actually if you can see there's the
British Library can you see behind is
some pancras station which is the new
Eurostar station which is actually a an
issue for the security of the British
Library the two highest priority and
excuse me the two highest risks were
actually wear and tear given that three
million items are issued every year in
the reading rooms and security which is
the price of giving access to 400,000
visits to the reading rooms but they can
obviously be mitigated I'd be very
interested actually either in the
debates or excuse me any questions
afterwards or with the reception if
anyone else has done these risk
assessments and because I think there's
a huge value in comparing results and I
do know of another organization which
have had a very unexpected result which
found that one of its major sources of
risk was from actually having box so
much of its material because what it was
a very high use collection and
everything as as the material was being
transported to the Reading Room's it was
getting a lot of it was very fragile
material in boxes that didn't that were
too big for it and was actually causing
a lot of damage
if if we turn this risk assessment ten
years ago at the British Library I'm
pretty sure that the results would have
been different I think the highest one
of the highest risk would have been from
environmental factors but since there's
been massive improvement in improved
buildings over 15 years that will take
the BL from before 1998 when it moved
into that that building you could say
none of its collection 0% of his
collections were in satisfactory
environmental conditions as it moved in
there which was where half the
collections went it went to forty-two
percent and then with the completion of
the massive new storage building when
that's full the new density store is
fallen in 2011 it will go to sixty-six
percent so over 15 years two thirds of
the collections will have gone into
satisfactory environmental conditions so
that minimizes that risk and I know the
Canadian Museum of Nature their risk
profile changed over time and they had
identified storage is a major issue and
then they made improvements and
unmitigated it and as to Harvard well
watch this space
I think I'll finish actually with a
couple of paradoxes and contradictions
around funding and will illustrate it
with the British library's Center for
conservation which some of you may
already have visited so preservation is
the custodian and champion of long-term
ism and yet ironically it's often
trapped in short-term decision-making
and funding and a nice paradox that I've
observed in my first few months here in
an endowment culture and is that a lot
of preservation is supported by non core
funding and soft endowment or fundraise
money the good side of this paradox is
that it does generally seem attractive
to donors and endowments but I would be
very very interested in your thoughts
and experience on this well and if the
BL I encountered in infuriating paradox
when we were fundraising for the 25
million dollar Center for conservation
which I was very heavily involved with
over nine years from its conception
through to its completion so this is the
now this is the back of the British
Library and is the Center for
conservation which is the first new bill
since that some pancras building was
completed in 1998 and there's the
Eurostar station at the back this was a
major project it included state of the
art studios for audio and book
conservation and fundamental absolutely
fundamental to the whole concept was
public access these studios were
designed to have weekly
behind-the-scenes tours for the public
and lectures and seminars
the entrance is a permanent exhibition
about what is inside the building and so
for example on the right there there's
an interactive where you as a visitor
can make decisions about how to conserve
I think it was a 19th century printed
book oh you can preserve a sound
recording such as I think this was
Nelson Mandela's trial tapes and you can
compare your restored version with that
of an audio archivists there was a huge
emphasis on training and development of
both staff and also of the profession
and we set up a degree foundation degree
in conjunction with the University of
the Arts were sponsored internships in
book pay for an audio conservation and
preservation so this was a high-risk
project it was the first capital
fundraising project for the British
Library and the irony was that we could
get funding for the training for the
internships and we could get funding for
the public program so that this
exhibition area we could have sold the
naming rights five times over but for
the conservation and we couldn't get
funding as that was seen as a core
mandate of the British Library and
ironically fundraising for the building
was challenging as well even though
usually people will support buildings
and equipment and not what goes on in
them and yet the irony was if we didn't
get the funding for the building we
couldn't do the activities we couldn't
do the conservation the training the
public programs that went on inside them
so lots of paradoxes lots of ironies
lots of contradictions
what are some of the lessons from my
professional journey from artisan
conservation when Roger Powell he used
to introduce all his assistants as
fourth-generation arts and crafts so
I've gone from artisan conservation to
strategic management in a large-scale
risa in large-scale research libraries
in a climate of cloud computing and
crowdsourcing well the spectrum of
preservation has got bigger broader
wider and more complicated from artisan
conservation at one end of the spectrum
there are many many more shades through
a whole rethinking of environmental
parameters of storage and energy
efficiency through two collections wide
risk assessment through two bitstream
preservation emulations and virtual
universal computing the spectrum of
preservations got bigger broader and
wider and all this chopping of
preservation and conservation into
little chunks of book and paper and
photographs and audio visual and digital
eat I don't think it makes sense anymore
they're all part of that continuum of
information of information mediums and
they're all interconnected then for
those working in the field no job is
unchanged mine has changed exponentially
almost beyond recognition a notion job
should be unchanged and no job will be
unchanged for those involved with any
aspect of preservation everyone's in
touched by these issues and should be
actively engaged with them in order to
remain relevant and all the next
generation being trained with that full
spectrum there's usually a time lag
where's my successor where are there are
enough people in the system who already
are spanning this spectrum
so preservation has changed and then the
nature of what's being preserved has
changed we still have the legacy of
physical collections and digitization
has become a lot more sophisticated as
the critical mass grows and projects
join up and digital scholarship mines
data and texts in new ways that's
challenging some of the assumptions that
underpinned preservation as it was
practiced even a generation ago now we
can use advanced technology to make rare
objects more accessible not less
artificially reconstructed objects can
be more authoritative than the authentic
fragments so coming full circle to my
first paradox about preservation being
about the future more than the past with
these futuristic ventures we can be more
true to the past so thank you once again
Bobby for inviting me I was very honored
to be asked to give this talk thank you
all for coming I'm extremely honored you
will cave and thank you for your
patience